Speaker 1: There is a very sick woman
in Arizona. No, not not Carrie Lake,
not Carrie, like I'm talking
about State Senator Wendy Rogers,
State Senator Wendy Rogers, 48 hours ago
said Carrie Lake might still be instated,
the governor of Arizona. Now, I want
you to answer honestly. Really? Tell me.
Do you believe Wendy Rogers believes any of what
she's saying or does she have to keep saying this
stuff because she started saying it and it would
be embarrassing to her to have to admit that she
was wrong. Take a listen to what she had to
say. Remember, Carrie Lake ran for governor
in Arizona. She lost in that. Her opponent,
Katie Hobbs, got more votes. Katie Hobbs is
now the governor of Arizona. Even if, for whatever
reason, Katie Hobbs resigned or died or whatever,
it would actually be the secretary of state of
Arizona that becomes governor. Arizona doesn't
currently have a position, lieutenant governor,
although they are creating it starting in a couple
of years. But here is what Wendy Rogers said.
Speaker 2: And I get asked this all the time,
especially do you, my district on various
rural radio stations, Senator Rogers.
Speaker 1: The radio stations must
be so rural that the people don't
understand how government works.
Speaker 2: You represent four other
counties other than Maricopa County. What hope
do you have of getting any of this legislation
passed? And my answer is twofold. Number one, I
was voted in by 27 percentage points to do the
very thing that I'm doing, which is represent
my constituents and make sure that my voters
were not disenfranchized. And number two,
they weren't. You never know everything that
will happen in terms of Carrie, like being
instated as governor. And I get asked this.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Also, I'm waiting to see
if maybe the Eagles actually won the Super
Bowl on Sunday. You never know. You know what I
mean? In a couple of months or maybe in a year,
it we might learn that it was actually
the Eagles who won, which is really,
really wild. My my head phone has just popped out
of my ear and it's going to be hard to hear the
following clip if I don't put it back in. There
we go. So do you think she believes this? Do you
think Wendy Rogers believes this? Or do you think
it's part of the grift? Now, here's a reminder.
The very same Wendy Rogers couple of months
ago, or one was it December, I guess December.
She claimed that Carrie Lake was the governor
elect of Arizona. She wasn't. And we had the same
question then. Does she believe this problem?
Speaker 2: And we need to get to the bottom of
all of this. And I just telling you, we're not
having it anymore. We're done, as Carrie said.
As Kerry said, you're messing
with the wrong people.
Speaker 1: Right. Is Kerry like the governor elect
of Arizona? Yes. Is there any doubt in your mind?
Okay. So just so you know, there's no lieutenant
governor in Arizona. The secretary of state is
next in line if anything should happen to the
governor. Death, resignation, impeachment,
whatever. Starting in 2027, the lieutenant
governor is going to become the would become the
governor upon the death, resignation or removal
from office of the governor of Arizona. And then
it would presumably go to the secretary of state.
So who thinks that Wendy Rogers genuinely believes
that any moment you might see the in statement
of Carrie Lake as governor of Arizona. And who
believes that Wendy Rogers knows she's lying.
But this is just the nonsense that she feels
she has to say for whatever reason. Let me
know in a YouTube comment. Send an email
to info David Pakman dot com, send a smoke
signal, telegram however you want to get in
touch. I'm curious what you think. I genuinely
don't know. I lean towards Wendy Rogers knows
this isn't true. There's no possibility of
stating Carrie Lake, but maybe I'm wrong.